this is a production of cornell
university
so first off uh thank you so much for
for the invite and i apologize that i i
couldn't attend in person um
unfortunately there was there was a lot
going on this week and we're prepping
for uh a board meeting um next monday
but my name is uh pat mccage i am the
first deputy director of the office of
cannabis management um
as i was kind of um saying you know
there is there is a lot going on um but
it's it's starting to really feel like a
real agency here um we're officially
over 100 ftes um so that's that's
exciting um we actually have like uh an
admin unit a legal unit operations uh
inspectors out in the field um so it's
it's exciting to kind of see see this
whole thing develop over the these past
kind of eight months
um and we're hoping to really continue
that momentum
into the fall and into the winter as we
uh expand the the cannabinoid hemp
program the medical cannabis program and
launch hopefully launch the the adult
use market which i know uh gets a lot of
the attention and is is really a big uh
big shift for for how
how just in regular everyday life uh for
new yorkers so
exciting times and apologize i i
couldn't be there in person
um so uh
today i'll just uh give a little
overview of of the cannabinoid hemp
program um and uh some update on some
other cannabis programs and activities
that are going on in uh in new york
state
so uh quickly uh just a legislative
background of kind of how we got here
the uh cannabinoid hemp program was
officially created in uh 2020
um the the it
came out of those research partnership
agreements in the research partnership
program
from the department of ag and markets
there was kind of a split in terms of
regulatory authority so
the cultivation as you just heard from
tim everything related to growing the
crop and harv up until harvest
is all at uh the department of ag and
markets and they you know follow the
usda regulations in the 2018 farm bill
but then
after that point anything that is
processed or manufactured
for its cannabinoid content so any of
those products that you've you know
probably been seeing around tinctures
food beverages
smokable hemp flour that is all
regulated uh by the office of cannabis
management um so the the program
originally started at the department of
health um and then similar to the
medical cannabis program was
transitioned over to this new office of
cannabis management when the
marijuana regulation and taxation act
the mrta
passed in uh march 31st of 2021
so
that transition happened in law uh
immediately but then it took several
months for us to actually stand up the
office and officially move people over
here hire new staff get a board
establish all those things so i think
officially uh it was the november um
third board meeting where we transferred
the regulations uh over to the office of
cannabis management which i guess we can
technically say you know the canada hemp
program um started uh here at the office
of cannabis management
and when we talk about cannabinoid hemp
and what we regulate
we really only only are talking about
products that are sold for their
cannabinoid content so not talking about
seed or
fiber products anything uh
related to just standard uh hemp food or
stuff like that that does not fall under
our regulatory jurisdiction um that
would still be under either ag markets
from a food perspective or the
department of health if you're like a
restaurant selling those those products
um and uh we were conscious to use the
term cannabinoid and not just cbd
um understanding there's many
cannabinoids in this plant and
uh as i i'm sure you've seen um you know
people are interested in in cannabinoids
beyond cbd and you know i think we're
starting to see you know cbn products
cbg products uh creep into the market
along with just general you know full
spectrum products that incorporate minor
cannabinoids terpenes and stuff like
that uh into their into their product
so the the reason for why this program
exists is really a stop gap measure uh
to to account for the fact that we have
uh hemp products cannabinoid hemp
products
widely available online
in stores throughout new york state and
throughout the country
however there's no federal regulations
that is that is governing
how these products should be
manufactured what should be included on
the label
um
because uh the fda has a primary
regulatory jurisdiction here they have
uh not taken any action really to to
regulate this industry because of a
pharmaceutically approved drug that has
cbd as an active ingredient in
um there's a number of bills in in
congress that would uh that would get fb
fda involved in the regulation of this
and kind of force their hand
i know they're looking at the issue i've
met with them i've talked with them
they're they're aware but you know
they're a very slow government agency
that is operating on on evidence that
typically takes years and years and
years to develop
and and research so um it's a bit of a
catch-22 at the moment and to to kind of
account for that fact that these
products are available um the
cannabinoid hemp program is intended to
offer some some guidance in terms of how
these products can be manufactured how
they can be labeled um and it's really
not meant to to reinvent the wheel
we're trying to point to regulations
that exist for similar products either
at the dietary supplement level or food
products or other cannabis products as
you see in like adult use or medical
cannabis programs
trying to kind of pull best practices
from from those three regulatory uh
you know kind of frameworks to to build
this this cannabinoid hemp program so
consumers are are aware of of what
they're getting um what's on the product
and uh you know i can't count the the
number of studies that have been done
out there where where a lab will just
sample some of the cannabinoid products
on the market and routinely you know 50
percent of them don't have what's on the
label they're either you know containing
x percent more cbd than they say they're
containing they don't sometimes don't
contain cbd at all they're sometimes
labeled as thc free and they have thc
which really can you know can be an
issue for someone who who has you know a
commercial driver's license or other
type of uh federal
um rules which would would uh mandate
them to to drug testing
so
um that is really the these three
bullets are the the
core i guess foundation of what the
cannabinoid hemp program is supposed to
do
so getting into some of those
requirements that are there we require
all of our processors to
follow good manufacturing practices
so part of the application process to be
a processor you have to get a gmp audit
of your facility um
they you know
from our understanding pretty similar to
how other uh products work and and if
the fda were to ever step into this
regulatory space they would likely
require this so we're hoping that you
know new york processors are going to be
a lake up from from maybe some other
processors in other states when when the
federal government does step into this
space
we require some some basic you know
packaging and labeling labeling how much
cbd is in the project uh making sure
that the consumer is aware of how much
thc is in the product
um
stating a serving size for the the the
product um that's one thing that we we
are learning we've actually done some
some focus group testing and some
surveys related to
to folks asking them you know what's a
typical dose
what does 5 milligrams of thc mean to
you
uh and it's really interesting because
even uh experienced users or people who
use cannabis frequently
they they don't know about the
milligrams of thc and how that interacts
and because
it's different for each user it's really
a difficult thing to try and regulate
and so
we're taking approach of you know
starting low going slow starting out
with uh lower serving sizes but you know
people can include more cannabinoids in
the product uh as long as it's just
transparent and aware for the consumer
and then lastly here uh similar to to
our medical cannabis and adult use
cannabis programs uh we do require
laboratory testing so each lot of a
cannabinoid hemp product uh needs to be
lab tested for a a list of analytes um
and uh is the the consumer should be
able to look up the certificate of
analysis uh for that lab if they ever
want to you know dig deeper and
have some uh reassurance that the the
lot did pass required testing
and so here you can see the uh amount of
licenses that we have issued to date
um
the the retail license really is more of
a registration um so anyone who's
selling can amazon hemp products in new
york state is required to get a a
license from our office to sell these
products
um we're over 3000 now for for retailers
the the application process probably
only takes around 10 minutes there's not
too many questions that that are
required um i think you have to just you
know prove that you have a certificate
of authority list what type of products
you're selling and then the the location
and your website
so it's pretty straightforward where
we're really trying to increase that
number because we do know that there's
likely uh you know four or five thousand
more locations that are selling uh
cannabinoid products just you know
because they are being sold at gas
stations and bodegas and cbd and vape
shops are really uh popping up in a lot
of locations that sell these products
um as you'll see you know we've now
licensed uh over or
just under 50 um
processors so that's really exciting
um
you'll see there's a little bit of a gap
between the number of processor
applications that have been submitted
and then the ones the number that have
been approved um the main reason for
that gap is
just waiting on the applicant to submit
all of their requirements and usually
the gmp audit is the last thing that a
processor will do
so
unlike some of the licenses in the
medical program or the adult use program
our our hemp licenses aren't aren't
competitive i mean if you meet the
requirements of the license you'll
you'll get be able to get the license so
um
the way we have structured the
application is you actually get your
facility you get your gmp audit and then
you can apply and receive that that
final license um so it's not it's not
like a thing where you're you're first
provisionally approved and then you go
find your location and then you write
all your sops it's one of those things
where it's when it's up and running then
it's ready to receive a license
and then uh just quickly on the
distributor permit
that's only required for
uh people who are selling products into
new york state to retailers uh that were
manufactured out of state and that is
just our way to kind of keep track of
the different cannabinoid hemp products
that are being
transported and distributed into new
york state because as we all know there
is a patchwork of laws out there as it
relates to cbd now
a lot of states have kind of followed
the new york model and have their own
specific cannabinoid hemp programs and
they all have different requirements
different testing standards different
packaging and labeling so
it's kind of our way of keeping track of
of you know which products are coming
into the state and trying to make sure
that they meet the requirements of the
new york state program
so uh one uh update here that is kind of
related to the hemp program but not
directly is uh we have started issuing
conditional cultivator licenses on on
the adult use side so uh a bill passed
uh earlier in february of this year that
would essentially that authorized uh
hemp farmers who had grown under the ag
markets program for two of the last four
years uh the opportunity to uh apply for
and receive a license uh to grow the
first adult use cannabis uh that has
been grown legally in new york state in
in uh you know ever
so uh that was really exciting we've
we've launched that application uh the
application actually has since closed um
i think we received over 300 or so
applications we've licensed
223 conditional cultivators um they're
all throughout the state from long
island to western new york to the north
country
um and a lot of different backgrounds
from these these hemp farmers as kind of
tim was alluding to some are you know
experienced farmers who grow 10 other
crops and this is just kind of one more
thing they're adding to their farm
operations
and some are completely new to it
they focusing on cannabis they might
have experience growing
in other locations or their own location
but uh it's been really interesting to
see that program uh roll out and and
it's exciting because uh if we waited
for um all our regulations and for the
licensing system to be up and running we
never would have been able to have uh
you know outdoor grown hemp this year
just because of of new york's climate so
that's really why the conditional
program was so important to get started
and then similarly that same bill that
passed in february also allows for
conditional processors um we're actually
going to be licensing our first batch of
conditional processors at the next
cannabis control board meeting
which is monday so so that'll be
exciting that'll be one more kind of
step in the supply chain to to making
sure that we have we'll be able to get
product uh up and running for when we do
launch the the adult use market
um this conditional processor license is
only available to entities that have a
license uh in the cannabinoid hemp
program and are licensed by the office
and have uh applied for that license
prior to january 1 2022 so that was just
kind of to prevent everyone who wants to
participate in adult use from you know
all of a sudden getting a hemp license
and then being being eligible for this
and you know we just wanted to have some
control over how many applications we
got for this uh initial go go around
and i also want to highlight too that
this is very much the the beginning this
is not the only um cultivator or
processor licenses we'll we're going to
be issuing
this really this whole conditional
program that we're launching was really
just done in a way to essentially jump
start
everything that we need to get done so
we can launch the adult use market
quicker
because one thing that
every that is at least has become
painfully aware to me
is uh the regulatory process like
following all of the state
administrative procedure rules and
issuing regulations out for public
comment soliciting those comments
responding with feedback reissuing the
regulations for a second public comment
period
waiting for an uh those that public
comment period to end that whole process
can take
six seven eight months so um you know
we really this was a a very innovative
idea um for for the governor to to
launch this program and get us hopefully
get get the adult use uh market launched
a lot quicker uh than than would have
been done
and also there's more information online
for both the conditional cultivator
conditional processor and conditional uh
or cannabinoid hemp program
on our website um some faqs guidance
documents stuff like that so you know if
you want more information please feel
free to reach out there
um or reach out to our office directly
there should be some contact information
on the website and i'll also share that
with
larry and the cornell team in case
there's any follow-ups
uh but but quickly too i just wanted to
provide a couple updates and next steps
from some things that are are popping up
and are maybe front of mind um in in
this uh this summer summer we find
ourselves in so one is
if anyone's following legalization at
the federal level uh
senator schumer and booker and wyden
just released their draft of the
cannabis administration and opportunity
act so essentially their bill to
legalize cannabis at the federal level
and uh there's some really important
things in there as it relates to hemp
and i think where where at least the
legislators are are thinking uh where
hemp is going and it could also
influence what the next farm bill will
be which we're already hearing a lot of
conversation about um you know
addressing hemp in the the 2023 farm
bill
so some things in that legislation that
quickly you know stood out to me was one
raising you know the thc content allowed
in hemp up to 0.7
it's not entirely clear why 0.7 was
chosen uh rather than 1 which i know the
industry has been lobbying at or just
keeping it at 0.3 percent so so that was
interesting
but uh and also they they seem to be
proposing the canada model for
cannabinoid hemp products
so essentially uh what canada has done
is they've in they've
allowed cannabinoid hemp products to be
sold but they're they're lumping them in
with adult use products and medical
cannabis products by setting the the thc
limit allowed to be in those products
really low uh like 100 i think it's like
10 parts per million
um which is what's in the the schumer
legislation um so what this would do
would essentially be if you have any thc
at all in a tincture a food product a
beverage product it would actually fall
under the cannabis regulations rather
than the hemp regulations so i'm
expecting there's going to be a lot of
feedback from industry on that
but it's also it's an interesting idea
because you know after all a lot of the
problems we deal with in our office
relate to how much thc is in a product
and and trying to make sure that the
products sold in the cannabinoid hemp
program are not intoxicating
while the intoxicating products with the
additional bells and whistles and
regulations would be more appropriately
sold through the adult use in the
medical cannabis markets
um and that leads to the delta athc
which is it's been a big one um just a
quick highlight there that we have
prohibited delta hthc in the cannabinoid
hemp program um it will you know most
likely be allowed in the adult use
program and is also allowed right now in
our medical program
but just because of the intoxicating
nature we're trying to kind of keep
those type of products out of
cannabinoid hemp markets
and then uh farmers markets we get a lot
of questions if can i sell uh
cannabinoid hemp products at a farmers
market the answer is yes
however the uh uh obligation to get a
retail license to do so is is a
requirement um so you know if you have a
retail license already for cannabinoid
hemp products that you sell either
online um just you know bringing that
documentation or having that included
when you set up at a farmer's market
will will count now in terms of a retail
license for for those operations
and then lastly just a quick note um
since legalization i don't know if
anyone's noticed but a lot of these uh
gifting stores have been popping up
since cannabis has been uh you know
decriminalized it's not an enforcement
priority for law enforcement which is a
really good thing however i want to make
it clear that these these these
that our office has not licensed any
adult use sales to date so any of these
stores any of these places selling these
products are not are not legal they're
not authorized by the office they're not
you know their products aren't being
tested there's often labeling concerns
they're often marketed towards kid
children with
you know neon colors and bright stuff so
you know very much please be aware um
when you're when you're
if if you do choose to to you know go to
one of those locations that you don't
really know where these products are
coming from our office is taking a
number of actions trying to uh shut them
down
while we also simultaneously uh
uh licensed products because
these will just you know hurt the the
illicit market that we're trying to to
establish so i kind of just wanted to
highlight that one
um and that that kind of is where we are
right now um you know there's there's a
lot going on
um we're hiring folks uh routinely so
you know if you're interested in a
career or know someone who might be
please check our website there's a jobs
tab where you can see
opportunities for for careers
and
we are looking forward to launching the
adult use program bolstering up the
cannabinoid hemp program and then also
making the medical cannabis program more
accessible for patients and
practitioners
um just a real quick highlight on that
we did recently release
proposed regulations which would
actually get rid of the registration
requirement for our medical program um
so uh
once someone would be just uh
authorized by their physician to to use
medical cannabis they wouldn't have to
then go to our office and get registered
to get registered excuse me uh just
trying to make it easier to essentially
be a medical cannabis patient
in the in the in the light that an adult
use market is coming and we want to make
sure that that medical market exists
because you know sometimes it does make
sense for someone to use cannabis uh
with a practitioner's oversight getting
that feedback you know they might be
taking other medications they might have
questions about dosing and so there's
there's a lot of
pros to to being in the medical program
even in in the existence of an adult
used market
so thank you you know please check out
our website um and uh email us at any of
the many emails that we have
and uh we will try and be as responsive
as possible and i'm open for some
questions if we have time
thanks very much pat uh unfortunately we
are out of time so to ask pat questions
uh so hopefully you snapped a picture of
all of those contacts there
and i'm sure i know they're very busy at
ocm and pat is incredibly busy but
i'm sure they will get back to you
when time allows so
please join me in thanking pat again
with a round of applause
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu